I think people underestimate to what
extent privileged especially white women
are willing to sacrifice their children
for the altar of status for them having
a trans kid is like winning the lottery
right and you laugh but it's it's really
the case it's very disturbing uh they're
are the only ones bringing their kids to
drag shows because for these affluent
white female liberals awful a man in
makeup is like the second coming and you
know they're showing dad or their
husband or whoever how enlightened they
are because this is what corporate media
tells them so they can't wait to bring
their kids and show how with the program
they are so they are a menace um and
this in my opinion is munchow by proxy
you know they're torturing their kids
for the sake of status and
accolades